the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright so today is the last official
day of lecture we'll finish up Joshua
and Kenneth reads and then we'll jump
right into post-production so whenever
you're ready laptops down
so the science of search have you ever
found it difficult to find a particular
item in your house let's say you have
lost a pair of gloves and you spend the
entire afternoon looking for it but you
just can't find it you have encountered
the same problem that companies like
Google or Yahoo try to solve every
single day the problem of search just
like a house which stores about a
thousand different items Google stores
45 billion different index pages of
information if each page of information
was a sheet of paper and we stack them
hi all together we would create a tower
610 times taller than the mountain verse
so how can a search engine like Google
find your results so quickly when we
find it so difficult to find a pair of
gloves well it turns out that searching
on the internet is kind of like looking
for a person in a hotel room let's
suppose we're looking for a guest called
James to find James the simplest way
would too would be to run to every room
nurse to you until you find him but that
would take very long there's a better
way known as binary search let's say the
people were arranged in alphabetical
order in increasing numbers of the hotel
rooms we could run the inn we could run
to the room in the middle and check if
the name of the person is James if the
person's name starts with a letter
before Jay we hit to the right if not we
will go to the left we then head off to
the middle room of the newly sectioned
area and we're inks and repeat
eventually we will find James just like
the first method but we found him much
faster than using the first method how
much faster would that be but that
depends on the people staying in the
hotel the number of people in staying in
the hotel let's say it takes 10 seconds
not on each hotel door and there's 500
people it would take about 18 minutes
for the first method and one and a half
minutes for binary search but if there
were a thousand people in the hotel room
it would take 160 minute minutes for the
first method but only one point six
minutes for binary search now that's a
whole
of difference so a name like James is
just a word but companies like Google
taken searches for long combination of
words making it a little bit more
complicated so just like identifying the
word James from its first letter Google
identifies unique characteristics of
search phrases using over 200 different
factors also notice how the better
matter depends on pre arranging the
people in alphabetical order computer
scientists are always actively looking
for better merits to stop to sort manage
and eventually retrieve the data in the
same way simply by placing your home
items in location where they have a
natural relationship to make it easier
for us to find them for example the TV
remote goes near the TV the shoes goes
near the shoe rack the coats go near the
cupboard and the winter gloves goes in a
winter jacket aha so that's where my
gloves are and that's the story of such
you're clocking in around three to four
minutes which is a really good place to
be alright so Joshua script is up on
annotation studio let me turn this on
oh sorry
joshua this script has come along a
really really far away this is really
tight very good I think the flow of it
is very natural I also thought your
delivery was very natural I don't know
if you've been practicing or maybe you
just felt a little more at ease today
but I think the way you pause at certain
words and just sort of the natural feel
of it is it's nice it sounds like you're
really just talking to us from Andrew
yeah when she said what was it that you
said during class you were sort of
copying her style a little bit
there we go
I think something that works really well
for the script is that you build
complexity which is a topic that we sort
of talked about earlier in the class but
i think is hard to really understand
unless you see a specific example of it
but he starts off with a very simple
example of losing your gloves and then
he clearly relates it to how Google
searches for something that is far
greater in number and complexity but he
connects it very clearly to the glove
analogy which is why I think it works I
think this explanation of binary search
is very clear because you're relating it
to the context of the hotel analogy so I
know in like earlier iterations of your
script you were just describing binary
search as a concept where people take a
set of data and then they split it in
half and then they search the data and
then they split it in half again right I
think that's the tendency that a lot of
us would have in defining concepts and
topics but for me personally I think
that this definition works really well
in the context of this video did anyone
have any thoughts about the script up
until this point up until like right
here
this is like purely cosmetic I thought
the script like I definitely understand
the basics of binary search after was
listening to you not even reading the
script so I think that's really good
just something I do I and this is you
can take it or you can leave it but
whenever I do like it's like 610 like I
don't know sometimes if I did like
hundreds of times the Mount Everest that
that kind of it can be a hundred it can
be like you know up to a thousand so it
it kind of scales it a little better but
that's very like you think that's okay
and like the other one was like over a
thousand different atoms like maybe just
thousands of items that was it I thought
the rest is really do I was really
beautifully written like just those
those layers of complexity in a way that
they you know I'm not someone who
processes particularly well just by
hearing something but the way that you
brought me from a simple a simple
concept to making it more complicated
and more complicated and then bringing
it back to the simple it was a
beautifully designed piece really well
but keep in mind this has happened over
several iterations and so I wouldn't
feel discouraged if maybe you feel like
your script isn't in as tight of a place
because if you look at your earlier
iterations I mean it was a very very
different idea a very different script
and we talked a lot after class F pretty
much every day last week but I think do
you feel happy with how it is right now
yeah you feel happy I think the
challenge is going to be in realizing
this visually because the script itself
is very tightly written but executing
the whole hotel analogy I think will be
really key and it's nice that you
actually have access to a hotel since
you're staying in the hyatt right now
but scaling back far enough so that
people understand oh the key to the
reason why this works is that people are
arranged alphabetically in a sense
numerical hotel rooms is a really vital
piece of information that you can use
the visuals to convey really well let's
see what about the second half of the
cert or of the script I don't think you
need this last thing right here I mean
that's what I was trying to say
yesterday that oftentimes we feel like
we have to continue the ending longer
than it needs to be so like this is why
this is awesome I you know this is and
that's the story of search and this is
the definition of prime numbers right it
reads a little like at the end you know
and I personally just don't think it's
as necessary but I like how you tied it
back to your opening I think it's very
strong
does anyone have any comments about this
at all yeah
the 80 minutes for the first method and
then one and a half minutes for binary
search you explain how you derive dat
because it's like 10 seconds in there
you know 500 people but then how do you
get the one and a half and I guess my
point is you might not need the let's
say it takes 10 seconds to knock on each
door that's an interesting point is you
could explain the calculations you did
to get to the binary search estimate but
again I don't think it's super necessary
to the point of the video cleaner
because I really think the one in half
minutes is very dramatic in the
comparison like I started pictured who
thought because I was also thinking
about like there could be like instead
of five hundred to a thousand it could
be five hundred to five thousand but I
don't know how how I'm not so sure
whether how realistic that was like
picture be of five thousand people in
the hotel but I mean I understand why
you brought up the specific numbers
because you're trying to show sense of
scale right that like the difference
between the two methods isn't as
exaggerated when you're only looking
through a few hundred items but when you
up that to thousands or even close to
what Google searches then the difference
in the time becomes super super dramatic
so in that sense I I mean I personally
am totally okay with having those
numbers in there because i think that
the script is written naturally enough
to where i'm not overwhelmed or
distracted too much by the numbers i had
one thought I know the hotel concept
works because when I think of a hotel I
think of a very simple box with like a
very linear line through it and roads
going off in different directions right
which is why it works but I wondered if
having instead of it being a hotel it's
looking for something at MIT
because then instead of it being
grounded at the hotel it grounds the
film on campus yeah be cool work with
like I'm not so familiar of the campus
is there please we're told it was very
uniform doors down the hall looks like
very very standard place with doors you
know but I just I just that was the only
thing that that fundamentally felt like
if we could shift it it would it would
help ground this instead of being at the
hyatt to being yeah that's a really
that's a nice suggestion and there's a
fun there a couple fun ways that you
could shoot that if you wanted to if you
wanted to shoot centered like this and
start whoever's filming you start
relatively close and you have the
classroom is branching off this way this
drawing make sense to people okay
instead you have to find some sort of
dolly maybe take a rolling chair but
then slowly pan back as he says but if I
had if there were like five thousand
people and then it's a nice reveal and
it sort of it's an exaggerated angle to
yeah yeah that'd be nice be rolled to
put their not a lot of time but it's a
fun way to brown this really
and think about and I was a experience
a really good place for that and that's
what I mentioned this
for if you go on the first floor then
it's just a standard and
all the rooms are pretty sure our
classrooms so they're available if you
want
enter them and then also there is an
exit thiru Killian Court so that may be
like in this location
and any final thoughts about the script
again I think it's come as a super long
way it's this is very this is pretty
much ready to film I think all right
Kenneth you are next do you mind giving
your mic to him yeah but I don't know
why I just said I just checked the link
it has the doctor what Google dog has
everything there's still like a few
paragraphs padova it's okay I'll just
read what i have yeah sure okay so um
how would you feel if you organize a
party and no one sense pretty much like
this one right now and then they'll show
me at the head of a table with lots of
wood and no one and say all right i
forgot to send the invites out and then
they'll cut to a shot me dropping the
sticks out I'm veloped into a mailbox I
say hmm wait a minute I guess the only
way that anyone could attend a party
right now is if they actually traveled
back in time but if they had received my
invite they would have traveled back in
time and I would have seen them and that
means I may not send out these
invitations oh right so and then after a
derby hey sorry this is actually why we
call a time paradox but let me just go
and talk about okay I'm ad-libbing right
now I'm sorry
yeah then somehow there's a transition
and no it's in the bay transition to
this neck signed but we could we
actually travel through time this was in
fact an experiment conducted by Stephen
Hawking's in 2009 to show that time
travel was probably improbable to be
invented even in the future but wouldn't
being able to travel to the time be cool
we could submit the homework that was
due yesterday boney completed today or
hates with a really cool party that i
Jes organized but how could we time
travel and is it actually possible a lot
of what we know about time travel or
what we think we know comes from
Einstein's theory of special and general
relativity now this is all part of what
we call modern physics and is still
being explored and tested as we speak it
doesn't mean that all of it is wrong it
just that means that we are so
unfamiliar with much of it as we are
with the universe around us now back to
time traveling when you think about it
we are all actually time-traveling but
not in the manner sci-fi movies has
often depicted them we are traveling
through time at a pace of one hour per
hour in other words as our bodies
experience an hour of time the world
around us has also experienced in our
war of time sounds simple but stay with
me this is where it gets interesting
within Einstein's theory of special
relativity there is a phenomenon he
describes which is known as time
dilation and in the noble subjects that
says dilation means to expand now the
gist of the filament lamp the gist of
this phenomenon states that faster you
travel the slower time passes around us
in other words at high speeds we could
be traveling at a higher rate than one
hour per hour this is however only
noticeable traveling at really really
high speeds near the speed of light
itself and then the C equals 2 3.0 times
10 to power 8 meters per second will
appear over here and say I invent a
spaceship that could travel at ninety
percent of speed ninety percent of the
speed of light and I have a pair of
newborn twins and I'll have two babies
in my hands cartoon babies and one of
them are put into this spaceship and
he'll be in the spaceship and I'll send
a spaceship off to space for a year
after the baby comes back for ya the
baby will have aged for one year while
the one that remains on earth where H
approximately two and a half years old
we
see that they have experienced times at
different rates and the baby on earth
had experienced times about a 2.3 Magnum
has experienced time at array of now two
point three years per year where we
travel at 0.9 see if my spaceship was
capable of traveling at even higher
speeds now fling the babies one side
this rates will increase exponentially
as shown in this particular graph as you
travel towards the speed of light which
is this part there'll be a graph overly
as you travel towards the speed of light
the magnitude of the time will change
dramatically and exponentially so we
could potentially travel forward in time
we just have to travel at extremely high
speeds to do so but I think the question
on everyone's mind is how do we travel
back in time I mean surely isn't a lot
more interesting and a lot sorry let me
just scrub it isn't it a lot more
interesting than traveling forward in
time do we have to run backwards really
really quickly and then we show the
flash running backwards across the
screen all this change is probably just
the direction we're facing as we travel
unfortunately and that doesn't seem to
be helping our case now looking back at
our previous graph we can see that the
amount of time that passes seems to be
SM topic to the speed of light what
happens on the other side of the graph
then scientist thinks that the idea
scientists think that the idea to think
that a secret to time traveling and
negative rates in subtext negative rate
equals time travel backwards lies on the
other side rephrasing that we would have
to travel faster than the speed of light
to maybe be able to travel back in time
and this is where the dicey part comes
in in general relativity Einstein
describes another phenomenon known as
relativistic mass when you have an
object traveling at high in our speeds
the mass of the object would increase
severely to move an object with higher
mass at the same velocity one would also
require a lot more energy Einstein
proposes that we as we put more energy
into an object both the speed and mass
would increase however as we approach
the speed of light there's more likely
that the energy put in increases the
mass of the object rather than the speed
of the object and trust to be able to
put in enough energy push an object
beyond the speed of light that will
require possibly an infinite amount of
energy and
rendering faster than light motion
highly unprovable but why are we so
obsessed with time travel time travel
often comes with its own set of problems
referring back to my initial problem and
say I do have friends in the future who
are capable of traveling back in time as
they receive the invitations after the
party and travel back in time to attend
it I wouldn't have had an auntie hattie
since I don't have an empty party I
wouldn't have to send out my invitations
after it and if I had not set on my
invitations they may not have received
it and they may not have traveled back
in time and this is where the whole
confusing part comes in and this is what
we call a paradox in fact this
particular paradox is known as a
grandfather paradox in which to a
conflicting series of events occurs
based on whether I choose to time travel
or not to time travel this is just one
of the tree theories of time travel and
more details can be seen in a link below
and then that will then get a youtube
description bar because if not the thing
that's really really long so it seems
our current understanding of modern
physics based on our current and
understand of modern physics time travel
might not be possible for us to achieve
yet that's not to say that things might
not change over the next decade or the
next century as we are slowly figuring
out the wall around us better but for
now if you're going to be planning a
party be sure to send out the invitation
before it and don't count on your
friends on being able to travel back in
time just to attend it yeah no it's ok
this is great stuff to work with and
actually I think that with just a couple
fixes you will also be pretty ready to
film as well so this is not your script
you you could open a google doc I just
I'm not sure because i'm updating it in
words of um no I'm Kenneth I know I'm
Kenneth
yeah yeah this should be it too
confusing yeah that's what I felt when I
was writing it but and the grandfather
paradox this yeah I actually I like how
you explain the paradox at the end
because it answers a question well if
Stephen Hawking proved that time travel
wasn't possible then why are we still
thinking about it now like what sort of
loopholes exist I think that may be
delicious um so I know that you had
restructured this I'm guessing you
restructured it because George had said
earlier you know it would be nicer if
you could actually get Stephen Hawking
in this video as you're talking about
the video or as you're talking about the
party um but all this can go away I
think that you can explain the set up
with just wait what you have like why we
need I mean I get I get that it's a cool
story right but I I feel like you
explaining this idea I I must admit that
I
yeah once in my life thought about time
travel ever before this woman it's not
something ethnic phone I don't even
think that i was kidding on thinking
about time travel because it seemed like
this very abstract idea that my brain
right we're capable of you did an
incredibly good job of helping me even
understand how someone would even think
about that idea which i think is the
beauty of your piece that's what the
essence of what you've done is you've
simplified really complicated set of
theories and all of that is something
that I now could follow and be like oh I
now understand how people to vote their
life into studying this idea i would
have never ever thought all this before
right this the party to me I don't need
it all in this to me not at the
beginning not at the end the idea is
time travel even possible it is
interesting enough without that story
from my perspective that I think the
party piece it's just it has so many
double negatives in it that it's just
really
it brought my round my head around I
just wonder what it would look like if
we took the party thing out entirely and
focused on I was actually thinking
alternative was maybe a b-roll of
footage from Hollywood films of people
traveling back in time in Harry Potter
or in Star Trek I mean then there's like
a whole IP issue which are going to talk
about in an hour I mean here's the thing
it and again this is the part where like
personal taste comes into play I think
that the story is nice to nice as a
storytelling element that you end the
video nicely because you reference the
beginning where you're just like just
send out your invitations but I do agree
that it takes a really long time to
explain it and I wonder if you can cut
this intro down into a sentence I think
this is an ok start held a party but
like you can take out all this stuff
with the leg he said the invitations no
one came how does that like I don't know
like it's really complicated
rest of this room but I really struggle
with this one thing I found when I was
redoing my people is like monitor screen
where you begin with and I think the
story I think it's good I think you get
a lot of those words bits up like what
we're shooting like no there's no one
there so the fact that you describing it
again I don't video gonna get over so
it's i like i like the Stephen Hawking
store but like it was obscenity probably
due to sentence based upon a visual cues
are in different video because I like
that you talk about the grandfather
paradox and and I I I actually didn't
super understand the grandfather paradox
until I heard you read this paragraph
aloud in the context of the party but
again Paul is totally right you can
completely rely on the visuals to tell a
lot of these words for you so you could
say back in the back in 2009 Stephen
Hawking held a party and he and I
Stephen Hawking held a party that no one
came to and he any smile at himself
because he had just proven that time
travel was possible all right so you're
reducing like everything down into a
sentence yeah is not possible the reason
is that he sent his invitations out
after the party had finished thinking
that if people in the future were
capable of time travel they'd receive
those invitations after the party had
ended and come so because the party was
empty you know time travel is not
possible you know what I mean like
really really condense it down to two
sentences like really challenge yourself
to explain the story in two sentences I
mean for me
actually one of the animation in this
part 2 just I don't know I don't know
why if I don't really know it it is it's
a complicated it's complicated because
you don't really explain it until the
very end which is okay like I agree that
it's not vital to the store like to your
content that the content is fascinating
enough but it's used really well right
now as the storytelling device to open
and close the video and then in the
middle you bring it up again I think
that there's a lot of stuff in the video
that you can take out that might give
you some time to play around with like
for example so this whole chunk can be
cut down a lot let me change this to
I'll just resolve this I think the
question that you can set yourself up
with is so if time travel if you
disprove time travel why are we still
fascinated by question or like why do
physicists still think about it well
what exactly is time travel a lot of
this like here I don't think you
necessarily need these two sentences
I also wonder if you need this paragraph
here yeah i mean it's it's fun it's also
it's going to be a little hard to
execute visually given the amount of
time that you have left and so just from
a production standpoint it'll be tricky
it's really word for me it did yeah like
Eddie's for me when you 18 I mean with
the babies you don't actually need both
babies even adults just concert yeah
right I really you don't have any weapon
as a mother like oh there's no way I
would lend you might help well no
offense but there is no way I would lend
you a child for this film um but I think
that like like this example actually was
very concrete okay yes I was just say
that example I thought was really good
too but then he came not the sentence
before with the area before you can turn
that the one thought because you're
explaining how you travel and Alec ran
our so I think you're able to just like
me get sentence out of that and just get
rid of the rest and then kind of blend
it with that now I take care of you
yeah I think the only issue with it is
that it takes so long to getting to
explain to how we travel backwards in
time and I don't know from the beginning
of the script that you're planning on
explaining that that I'm just sort of
waiting to see where you'll go next so
maybe if you preface you preface like
I'm going to explain what time traveling
is you can say well you know first in
your own words you can say for some
where I talk about how we travel forward
in time and then backward in time or
somehow indicate that to the viewer I
don't know if anyone else felt that
confusion sorry Andrea mmmm that's like
you know let's do this experiment what
yeah experiment where we do this yeah my
I think it will help with you're facing
it was difficult for me to listen to it
was pretty worried here I think if you
actually like just grabbed two props as
though you're acting it out and ad-lib
it and record yourself doing it you'll
get something that close a lot better
you can't be able to cut out a lot of
words because you'd be able to can the
11 year old baby here's a
two-and-a-half-year-old pocket yeah and
there are a lot of just like little
phrases like this like we are with the
universe around us that are very poetic
right like face I'm really nice in an
essay but if you actually strip some of
this away and really just try to distill
it down to the essential facts I think
that's going to save you a lot of time
too but overall at this point it seems
more like distilling ideas sound do
people agree with that I'm glad that you
fleshed it out though because that
before it was sort of missing some of
the the essential explanations and I
know you were worried about it getting
too long because of it but I think that
um I think the overall structure of it
is very sound
well I was going to say that the topic
of
all of the topics involved in the script
kind of to me don't seem necessarily
connected because the paradoxes are more
in the field of law
relativity's physics and then the twin
paradox is a thought experiment so
that's closer to philosophy
so I think it would be nice to kind of
separate the two to mention you this is
actually scientifically proven and this
is just something that people think
about also the most compelling part to
me was and that's something that answers
the question of time travel the best was
the part where he talks about traveling
forward in time and traveling backwards
in time and the backward part is not
very fleshed out whereas there was a lot
of times but on the toilet area dogs
that doesn't necessarily have to do that
which with time travel
so I do think that there is a way to
restructure it or like focus on
something other than China travel and
that would be paradoxes that arise when
just traveling in this beauty
the twin paradox immigrant
and then you could explain them in more
detail and especially for the
grandfather paradox that would help
because you could split up the
explanation in two different sentences
so you would infuse would've had
multiple times I mean the only thing is
that you are working with a very tight
time constraint and I think like I think
all of this information is nice and it's
good and it helps me understand it
better and would work really well if
this were a blog post for instance but
you do only have four or five minutes
and I actually like the structure that
you have waiting until the end to
address the paradox because you're kind
of going back to the beginning and
you're saying you know why isn't time
travel possible aside from the fact that
we can't go beyond the speed of light
you know how else are you going to
support Stephen Hawking's claim that
time travel is impossible so I I like
that the way you've split up putting the
paradox at the end and I don't know how
you guys feel about it how do you feel
about the overall structure of the
script
nagasu Gideon I'm very embarrassed
should be after the matter
oh yeah because
and in it he earned me my wrong
for an affair with because of your so
nobody knows
we're wasting time so you can give a
break coffee
or like gentle analogous
I just thought that first thing in the
start on TV like tug is laid out that I
feel like most of the work is just
shortening individual parts yeah I i
agree with Nathan on that and honestly
the thing about the travelling backwards
in time for me personally it's just that
you don't get to it soon enough so that
I feel like we're waiting through a lot
of intro and a lot of explanation of
wheeling forward which are important so
I wouldn't say take them out completely
or anything but that I I had no idea
what any of this was actually before I
read this and it's like I'm glad that
you put it in there because that's
really what the meat of it is like what
exactly does it mean to travel back in
time and at first I was like why is he
putting graphs up like this is being
really physically but now I understand
why you're talking about the asymptotes
and everything it's just that it took a
really long time to get there so like if
I here we go
Farrah and cutting information either
even the overall structure works but
there's just too much yeah i think this
paragraph is very vital and I wouldn't
shorten that unless you're like going to
take out fluffy words if anything I
would take out from the stuff before it
and this stuff is super interesting and
I I don't want you to take it out
because it's a further explanation of
why time travel is impossible but it
gets really dense here like this is the
part when you were talking where I was
like what is happening yeah
like this is ok but this paragraph
can you just say that would it would
also need a lot more energy actually an
infinite amount of energy to move it so
traveling faster than the speed of light
is highly improbable just afraid it
condenses the whole chunk on traveling
back in time yeah that's why I decided
to talk a little more ya know and I'm
glad that you flush it out I know that
you were hesitant to add more stuff
because you were aware of the time
constraint
mention equals x is very not exactly
it's effectively it goes i'm using the
ultimate e equals MC squared and as you
increase e as increases normal you think
i am stay the same and see increases a
social equals a camera MC squared that's
why i didn't really want to bring it it
yeah yeah i don't think you should add
any equations to this aside from the
fact that like equals MC squared is like
the characteristic Einstein equation
that people's but the thing is it
doesn't really put it explain this
that's why I didn't really feel like
putting the other equation I I agree
with Jamie overall like the structure I
think is there the substance is there I
don't think you necessarily need to add
anything except for maybe a transition
or or so but at this point I really
think it's just again being ruthless
about taking words out taking a sentence
out or to your only over by a few
minutes which actually is an eternity
yeah yeah yeah I think I started getting
lost around the Einstein because you
were talking a lot faster in that
section 2 and but I I'd say at this
point it's really like just paring it
down to the essentials and I can we can
help you with that during office hours
if you want any final thoughts for
tennis yes Joshua
No
yeah i was thinking whether i should
even mentioned a paradox straight off or
not to mention it at the top that's why
i was just playing around and yeah i
think no you think the double negatives
are confusing yes yes
it's best maybe
but so he makes it very clear that like
once
it may be a little
and you might lose our complex
what people
I guess it's not an intent to help them
understand this
terrific
ok
Trent was wrong
then might be okay
hi tech city area not before my keep
thinking about why is that why is that
more happy they proved very popular and
you talked about it at the end I think
the whole grandfather paradox part is
nice because it is an expansion of why
maybe his proof wasn't really a proof
and why people are still thinking about
time travel even though he supposedly
proved that it wasn't possible wouldn't
you take this Richard approach Josh cook
it's cool
little part make it really simple at
first even hawkings posted a party no
one showed up improved the tempo was
possible actually it's a little more
complicated yeah actually back you could
open the video like that yeah and then
and then it allows you to use that story
throughout but not confusing people with
all the details right
all right any final thoughts I mean this
is in good shape too again it's much
easier to I think it's easier to pare
down from something that has too much
content then the other way around for
sure so yeah and the delivery again will
help too they really have I mean I don't
know if you guys have looked at your
pitches that you made last week but they
really have I mean I'm really excited to
watch these videos I'm just going to say
that I really like how
we're able to explain this this complex
phenomena words that are interesting
and that's the whole like building
learning confidence with the viewer to
that I talked about on the first day of
like simple explainer videos are so
compelling to people even though there
are quote unquote boring because people
feel good when they feel like they've
mastered a seemingly complex subject and
this is a video that is going to help
people understand special relativity so
I think that it's going to be a very
compelling thing to watch for people
they're going to want to keep watching
it because they're understanding what
you're saying all right yeah yeah you're
helping them achieve mastery which is
nice